bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi domenica quindi siamo su happy with
volevo partire soltanto scusandomi se
ieri che era sabato
non ho messo video che in italia nel
week end ci dovrebbero essere video
addirittura speciali invece ieri non ho
messo niente perché avevo registrato una
puntata di happy with ma purtroppo il
file della webcam era andato perso per
una volta raga per una volta cosa che
non ho mai fatto finora
voglio provare a registrare un video
senza fare neanche un taglio cioè
taglierò soltanto quando passerò da un
livello all'altro ma nell'arco di un
livello voglio provare a non tagliare
neanche una volta è un esperimento che
voglio fare e fatemi sapere alla fine
del video se preferite che tagli oppure
che che faccia video così come come sto
per fare adesso va beh comunque come
primo livello andiamo a giocare a
special ball
trovo che me lo avete consigliato sin
dal primo episodio e non so che cos'è
non ho idea del perché raga mi abbiate
consigliato proprio questo tra tutti
boltro che ci sono perché ce ne sono
un'infinità lo sapete è però vabbè siamo
con eddy è partiamo anche perché non so
che cosa di speciale allora victory sull
price che cos'è victories al pride non
lo so
cos'è sexy time oddio ok questo non
censuro voi sentirete soltanto
dall'audio che sta succedendo un
qualcosa di mio zio ma è possibile una
cosa del genere ma che schifo
vabbè dall'audio potete intuire io non
censuro per sicurezza
vabbè andiamo avanti morbo perfetto
poi c'è mai questo soggetto che cosa
idiota vabbè babbo natale è andato non
so 9 like sisley are you later then no
andiamo avanti
oddio questo lancio più lungo del mondo
victoria loc
ho sbloccato la vittoria raga devo
raggiungere l'ultimo canestro già fatta
no quasi quasi quasi quasi quasi è un po
difficile farlo ma vabbè mike hall di
nuovo ma perché che poi parte che non
sono anche se si dice mai che non hai
giallo ok
ciò mi sono rimaste 5 mi son rimasti
cinque palloni e impossibile raga prima
che prende al traguardo
si no no b addio stanno stuprando luke
perché stanno stuprando gli urti
lasciamo perdere cos'è sta roba niente
l'ho sbagliato lancio si si no quasi
quasi ci devo risentito riuscire o mai
lag perfetto niente no no no no zero
quasi ce lo fa devo riprovarci da calori
provarci almeno una volta spero di non
riuscire a di beccare di nuovo a tutti
quei casini di prima vittoria all'occhio
perfetto vai
ok perfetto no no no no no no no no
vinto
ho vinto ho vinto col corpo però in
teoria dovrei lanciare non è non sono
sulla vittoria se non su sexy time in
teoria doveva lanciare il pallone lì ma
va bene ok raga proviamo high scores non
abbia di che cosa sia al che era che
partiamo subito con steve sono su un
fiore si sembra un fiore va beh non so
che cos'è vado avanti
ok oddio oddio perfetto ok non è
esattamente la partenza che mi aspettavo
intanto quei pezzi di odio le gambe si
stanno ancora dimenando va beh riprovo
ma all'inizio ma che il casinò fa quando
cadde vabbè lasciamo perdere comunque
steve non si lascia neanche sopraffare
diciamo dal clima a meno 20 gradi perché
come potete vedere lui e sempre in
maglietta e pantaloncini è perché si
tiene in allenamento col poco
giustamente ragal poco rischia da un
casino provatelo
va beh oddio c'è c'è il papa maledizione
vai col poco vai no no maledetto stronzo
ma attacco dello scorpione
ok già sto facendo ho vinto io qualcuno
a qualcuno si è staccata una gamba non
so che spero che di non essere io non
ero io non è maledizione però non sono
rimasto no no no ma merda va bè ragazzi
rinuncia è troppo difficile sono
impediti livelli come al solito raga mi
avete fatto un livello anche stavolta
anzi me l'avete fatto i due adesso
andremo a giocare entrambi il primo è di
hi tech e epic jump forza vj ciao fa vi
ho fatto livello parte spero che ti
piaccia ciao bello grazie per il livello
perché ho fatto un arriva bruttissima e
vabbè iniziamo allora c'è qualcosa qui
dietro c'è tipo una roba
ok ok non era esattamente il tipo di
partenza che mi aspettavo e tipo lancio
del giavellotto
ok non perché del giavellotto ma che sto
dicendo beh vabbè lasciamo perdere
rifacciamo siamo partiti ma di secondo
rossarola penso che fosse per gli yuck
ok baiocco e tutto per te ok
partiamo senza luke allora ricorda che
spaziatrice la frenata c'era scritto va
bene allora me lo ricorderò non so che
cosa mi serve però va bene vai cos'è by
bike
oddio oddio mi stanno arrivando un
miliardo di frecce però sono ancora vivo
da questa parte sempre giu ok vado vado
vado vado vado pieno di vetrina no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
ok per chi vuole cadere anche un
frigorifero per caso non perfetto che
sono morto ci devo ritrovare un secondo
credo di aver capito adesso che funziona
la cosa però la roba di io coi vetri da
che ci faccio sempre a cazzotti diciamo
perché è impossibile ci avete mi si
impicciano sempre e mi ammazzano
i vetri da oggi ma perché perché perché
maledizione perché ci sono ragazzi sono
di nuovo ok ok ci supporta perfetto
allora piano ce l'abbiamo fatta
fino a qui ovviamente allora superiamo
superiamo luke ce l'abbiamo fatta fino a
qui fino a qui ovviamente ok mancano i
vetri i vetri stavolta no stavolta no
stavolta no
ok ce l'ho fatta ce lo faccia mi sto
portando avanti 12 tonnellate di vetri
non importa ho vinto ho vinto ce l'ho
fatta raga allora grazie per il livello
ai check
va bene è già un miracolo che si è
riuscito a farlo faccio che fare l'altro
altri ha tradotto mi avete detto
nell'ultimo episodio che è vivi è
piaciuto lo sfondo di uno vi ringrazio
raga si vabbè perché mira i nichilo l'ho
visto unanime figo e vabbè lasciamo
perdere maicon l'altro livello che il
caricamento veramente sono rimasto
sorpreso e di quanti quanti siano
riusciti a riconoscerla comunque di
sfondo veramente grandi raga non me lo
aspettavo
comunque andiamo con nonno ciak tutto
per te favi cos'è sta roba non andare
qua ma tu lo stai facendo apposta cioè
tu lo sai che se tu scrivi non andare
qua e la prima cosa che faccio per non
andare devi scrivere cibarci cure ok
perfetto sono morto ok sono diventato
una pignata ok direi di cambiare
personaggio allora diamo con steve
ok non credo di averlo ancora utilizzato
raga ok nell'episodio di oggi ma non
importa andiamo andiamo andiamo
mi sono incastrato maledizione ok
perfetto devo riuscire a superare sto
pezzo badovic
mamma mia che boss che boss ok oddio
cos'è quel un arpione merda ok devo
riuscire a superarlo senza farmi colpire
piano piano piano si è mamma mia che
ninja vedo anche delle mine ma non mi
fatti perché le ho viste quindi riuscirò
a superarle senza farmi niente perfetto
ok ancora no no no no no no no no no
ok sono ancora vivo sono ancora vivo di
nuovo continua a essere vivo e come fare
delle punture perfetto
mamma ok io e il poco siamo diventati
una cosa sola
ok io pensavo che quella effettivamente
fosse il casco però
evidentemente non lo era ci riprova
un'ultima volta raga ok ragazzi
no no ma perché dai che ci posso
riuscire lo stesso maledizione è come
fare le punture steve concentrati ce la
puoi fare
ce la puoi fare no no no non puoi
mollarmi adesso no ok ok allora piano
calma già possiamo fare scola calma ci
si si si non ci [ __ ] mina di merda
no no no no no no no no no no ok ci
rinuncio ti ringrazio spotless però è
troppo difficile
ti ringrazio comunque lo stesso sport
scusa se non sono riuscito a finirlo ma
è colpa mia sono impedito perdonami
andiamo su kill your boss mi sembrava di
aver visto kill your bones perfetto
anche questo qua mi ispirava un casino
why did you sleep with my life cioè sta
roba è la cosa più stupida che abbia mai
giocato
vabbè riprovo un attimo che cos'è e
chuck che se la prende col padre di uk
che va a dormire con sua moglie però va
bene non ho fatto il senso di sto
livello non ha non ha senso che cambiamo
you can be the ass
sei proprio sicuro mi hanno detto che
non possiamo finire questo livello
forse non ci conoscono abbastanza
comunque va beh proviamoci
vai steve vai vai cose state però devi
arrivare vivo se non funziona
ok ripro secondo ok perso il casco
subito fantastico ma cos'è quella roba
lì che c'è una mina non l'avevo mica
capito sta cosa allora devo riuscire a
superarlo senza toccarla forse magari sì
no no no no ok ho sbagliato tutto va beh
ci riprova e allora sto livello è
decisamente un casino è assurdo
ok ce lo fa la mina andata la mina
andata mi è andata ok se provi lasciare
ok no non è esattamente quello che avevo
in mente
però ho vinto col poco è già un
traguardo ci riprova un secondo
devo riuscire a buttarla via se si va in
tv no no no
l'ultimo tentativo poi basta ci si no
sono arrivato io non ci posso credere
ok soddisfazioni ragazzo addis fazioni
gara padre figlio ok penso che debba
utilizzare gli utenti
beh no maledetti ma sono partiti in
vantaggio non è giusto che la testa di
duke è già andata [ __ ] e vabbè
lasciamo perdere
you can't wait è veramente sono andato a
stanza lento perché gli occhi mi
appesantisce vai via luke via youtube
ok sto di bello aveva qualche senso no
rock swing raga l'avevo fatto nel primo
happy meals non so che come potrà essere
in questo secondo è più se vado con
nonno ciak è un caso o dio ma che c'hai
razzista roma c'è ma la sedia di nonno
ciacca i razzi non lo sapevo no
veramente sta cosa assurda
allora nel prossimo livello vedrò di
utilizzarlo perché voglio provare la
sedia a rotelle a reazione non lo sapevo
vi giuro non lo meno tratto vabbè
comunque guaita second andiamo di joe
c'è sta roba che non ho capito che cosa
si è molto simile al primo comunque va
beh
grandissimo chat no no ma sono ancora
vivo
facevo fatto che vai giù vai giù
perfetto perché attacca c'è grandissima
donna mia ma che atleta che atleta
potrei andare allora mamma mia
il prossimo livello olimpiadi per nonno
ciak ok ragan neon world tra ok perfetto
non è partito uno smog trova meglio in
un livello almeno in un video di epic
games ci vuole sempre lo farò sempre
perché sono fantastici sia i ball
troicki che gli sport trova almeno una
volta li devo fare perché sono veramente
epici comunque vabbè 33 in un lancio
assurdo è andato via ed il uk che si
deve levare perché la sua è una spada
non la perdo per luke vabbè proprio
vedere se riesco a lanciare uk per
colpire la bambina è vai a giocare male
detto ok esattamente non volevo fare
così ho vinto ho vinto che sta
succedendo maledetto gli occhi mi stai
facendo uccidere
ok vi è finito andiamo su nerone botto
run tutine on
andiamo con nonno c'è questa volta che
voglio provare la sedia a rotella
reazione che vivo
poi non strada ma non lo sapevo ok a
parte che ho perso lo stesso ma vabbè
non sapevo veramente che avesse la sede
della razione maledizione vai nonno
perché anche senza il corpo ben si sa
ancora bene ok ci vai
poi così vai così se devo riuscire a
spiccare il volo e da un uomo se ok ok
ok ho detto
raga e ho scoperto una cosa incredibile
non sapevo veramente che la sedia a
rotelle di nonno ciak servisse a questo
è fantastico samurai showdown no paura
di cosa possa essere o dio siamo ok
perfetto luke padre
cos'è sta roba oh mio dio confucio cos'è
cos'è perché c'è il nonno ciak che si
improvvisa samurai
vabbè non sa che lo sappiamo abbiamo
visto prima casa e le qualità
incredibili come atleta e quindi ho
paura di non riuscire a vincere a
livello ma proviamoci lo stesso ok ok se
se ho perso due addio all'ora verso le
braccio persone
no ho perso un braccio l'altro i segni
attaccato però sono ancora vi ero vivo e
rovi perfetto stanno continuando oddio
allora luke dimise profuma mio didietro
fammi sapere perché sei venuto a 6
svenuto cosa
ok ci riprova un'altra volta suo livello
è veramente un casino come del resto
tutti gli altri però
se dato che abbastanza lungo credo per
diventa ripetitivo
se riesco a infilzare nonno cia che modo
da utilizzarlo oddio mamma mia che mamma
mia che no no no non è giusto non è
giorni stuprano mi stupro non stanno
stuprando che cosa è successo
ok è una cosa molto oscena meglio che
lasciamo perdere allora cambiamo livello
un'altra volta facciamo scorsa ostacoli
a caso proprio un primo che mi è venuto
allora liuc è partito
aspettate ok vabbè look non partecipo a
questo livello meglio un peso in meno
allora vai lento ok allora notate la
posizione di relax che assume quando
muore il padre di youtube cioè sembra
quasi che si stia fumando una sigaretta
non lo so vuoi qualcosa
vuoi un tè la pesca non so dimmi cosa ti
porto non ho capito la bella jean
perdere comunque vai luke baille prima
cosa
ok se sono ancora vivo [ __ ] ci
devo riprovare eh no ma è possibile
ragazze o per la mente san fermo se non
funziona
dai dai dai dai se ho vinto
si no ma che cazzo ok ok ci sono di
nuovo ci sono di nuovo perfetto no no no
no
ok ok perfetto ci siamo luke stai pure
li devo ritrovare dopo va a prenderla
ricattatorio già partito
la patch ha quindi va bene ostacolo tre
veri siglos brake ok bass mi spaventa
perché sto già per morire ma non importa
ok non ci sono riuscito dove prendere un
po più di rincorsa
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye così vai
così se è stata di potenza a short che
c'è gol e se non lo sa che dice tu non
puoi passare è in effetti non voglio
passare il l'asse tranquillo no no
ok ci siamo ostacolo finale la battaglia
no padre contro figlio luke contro il
padre ok allora liuc
se vinci tu ti mando a letto senza cena
maletto stronzo allora come faccio ma no
facciamo la vecchia maniera arrivo ok ok
cos'è se rocco dio livello 3
little delitto chef allora questo è
scelto nida piccolo perfetto ok no no
madonna mi sono ficcato una mannaia nel
didietro ma sono ancora vivo ok
stiamo per bene ok era ancora vivo non
sono ancora vivo sono solo senza braccia
sono quasi al traguardo ce la posso fare
beh ho vinto ho vinto di strada
distruggi la terra questo mi ispira un
casino
ok missile termonucleare siamo partiti e
non fa niente
mio dio che cosa epica ok perché c'è il
cartello che indica marte
me lo dovete spiegare non l'abbiamo che
questo non è un livello non ha senso
però è fatto benissimo vabbè andiamo su
chille your wife
ok spero che sia è di noè non ciak greg
this and gold up che aspettate un attimo
perfetto ci sono
mio zio ma cos'è stato ma che sei sasso
livello oggi a santa aspettate che non
ha senso sta roba
ok dovevi pulire casa maledetta
scansafatiche
ok raga come ultimo direi di chiudere
con lo stunt park che mi che dal titolo
mi attira un casino
vai york facevo vedere quanto siamo
freestyler allora è una cosa un po
strana si si vede subito però io e luke
non ci lasciamo ok non ci lasciano
sorprendere va uk vaio che cosa fai
vedere il salto della morte va il rock
so che io che lo troveremo alla fine
ragazza alla fine vita
ok come non detto
lasciamo perdere andiamo avanti addio ok
mi è partito a sellino dell'ikea
maledizione abbiamo pagato un casino
lasciamo perdere
ok sono ancora vivo se sono vabbè che
nonostante perché non dovrei morire
credo le ultime parole famose che forse
colti di uvetta perché sono un pro
ok ci siano posso ancora accelerare
forse se guardate tutto su una ruota
raga by cos'è finale incredibile con la
scocca e ci sono delle monete lì che non
ho preso ma non importa
vabbè raga direi che posso chiudere qui
perché non so quanto sono arrivato di
video non ho ottenuto il tempo mi scuso
se appunto ieri non ha fatto uscire il
video scusatemi anzi oggi l'ho fatto
anche un po improvvisato comunque come
al solito a dimenticavo di dire che tra
poco uscirà appunto l'episodio di the
grudge quello bello lungo che vi avevo
promesso e quello spaventoso per
recuperare tutti gli altri episodi è e
poi vabbè scrivi per l'asma va bè questo
già lo sapete mi serve telecomando
perfetto come al solito ragazza e video
vi è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina facebook e come al
solito trovate nella descrizione di ogni
mio video se non siete a quelli siti
scrivetemi noi ci vedevano passi un
video bella ragazzi